hi there Steve coffin here today I want
to talk a bit about the conference that
I attended in Portland and touch on some
very important concepts I think in
language learning and this revolves
around comprehensible input compelling
input repetition noticing so let's start
with the conference the conference was
part of a call it a movement or a group
of people involved with language
teachers who promote the idea of story
listening and I'm gonna put a link here
in the description box or you can find
out more about it if story listening as
a technique as a way of teaching
language and story listening is part of
this comprehensible input see I I may
have referred to it in the previous
videos compelling input which of course
is the ideal but comprehensible input as
being the main way you know accessing
comprehensible input meaningful messages
that we can understand is the main way
in which our brains acquire the language
so how does this translate into an
activity in the classroom and then I
which is what the conference was most
about and then I'm gonna talk a bit
about my perspective as a learner who's
not in a classroom so the story
listening presentations were about how a
teacher with a whiteboard can tell a
story in a very animated way whereby
through the sort of animation and the
drawings on the whiteboard and just a
very sympathetic and enthusiastic nature
of the teacher meaning is imparted so
that learners who are not very familiar
with the language actually start to
follow the story and Benny Co Mason who
was the main presenter she has evidence
that her students even only once a week
participating in this kind of a class
end up acquiring more words and
improving improving their toy score more
than traditional is the case in
traditional classrooms now she did also
say that these stories animated lively
fun stories tend to get the students
reading more and the regional agreement
that ultimately we have to read a lot in
order to improve our vocabulary in order
to get better in the language to better
on toy tests and so forth stephen
krashen was there in his inimitable way
he played the piano he was charming he
was funny and he explained some of the
key aspects of his comprehensible input
hypothesis he made it very clear that
aha and hypothesis in science is a
possible explanation of a phenomenon and
if it's possible to demonstrate that it
doesn't explain whatever phenomenon it
is like language acquisition then of
course the hypothesis is disproven but
so far there has no been no evidence
that comprehensible input doesn't lead
to language acquisition there are
competing theories and I'll get to that
so as stephen krashen presented about
comprehensible input and then he also
made a second presentation where he sort
of said that the stages in
comprehensible input are first of all
stories which is what we were being
shown these you know engaging ways to
tell stories in class then the second
stage is in his mind
fiction even very you know lowbrow
fiction and then the third stage is when
the learner can then go out and read
whatever they want all right so after
the presentations after the conference I
was at dinner with these teachers by the
way all of the teachers were extremely
enthusiastic and positive and I think
that's a tremendous quality for a
teacher to have enthusiasm their skills
in the languages they were teaching were
you know varied
from very good to less than very good
but certainly competent which to me is
not an issue because there's so much
native content available that the
teacher doesn't have to be the only
source of the the language so but at the
dinner it was made you know the teachers
explained to me that that within
comprehensible input there's this story
listening is a theme or basically one
stream whereby the teacher does most of
the talking tries to elicit some
response from the students but basically
it's the teacher telling the story the
second stream is T PRS teaching
proficiency through reading and
storytelling whereby the teacher and the
learner sort of develop the story
together so there's more participation
from the class and the third stream is
oh and in this T PRS however the class
will focus on specific grammatical
structures or specific vocabulary themes
or something during the classroom and
the third type of CI activity in the
classroom for it I could gather is some
a form of TP RS where the classroom is
engaged with the teacher in building a
story together but it is not limited to
any specific vocabulary area or
grammatical patterns or anything it's
just a free use of the language in
building a story together with the
classroom now it's obvious that this
this commit comprehensible input in
whatever form has a number of
significant advantages it appears that
people learn better that the students
acquire more vocabulary end up speaking
better and have better comprehension
than the conventional grammar based form
of instruction the second big advantage
is that there is a lot less testing and
a lot less therefore work for the
teacher in correcting tests after the
class so that it's beneficial for the
teacher and is beneficial for the
student win-win
the my perspective of course is not that
of a teacher in a classroom I've never
been a teacher in a classroom I am a
learner and I observe other learners at
link for example so I have some things
where I have a slight disagreement for
example when I sat down with the
teachers for dinner
and I said that when I'm learning
languages of link I like to have 10 to
15% unknown words in the content that
I'm listening to and that's oh no no you
can't you have to have like 98% known
words and that may be true if you are
free reading it may even be true in a
classroom but as an independent language
learner given that I start out with a
hundred percent new words unknown words
you know if I try to limit myself to 90%
known words I would take forever to get
anywhere and if you are in an
environment such as link where you have
access to online dictionaries where you
have the audio you can click on words
and see the meaning right away you can
click on words or phrases see the
meaning here then pronounce granted
text-to-speech then you didn't listen
the natural audio again you can take it
away and listen several times go back
and read again that this in this
environment you can actually tackle more
difficult material and progress more
quickly if you you know take on a higher
percentage of unknown words now you have
to be motivated you have to be willing
to deal with the uncertainty of having
maybe 20% of the words there that you
don't understand the first time through
you have to be willing to go back to it
again all of those things are true and
maybe that doesn't work in a classroom
but so that there's there's the first
thing I think you know we should
challenge students in my opinion maybe
even in the classroom to take on content
that's a little more difficult than just
2% unknown words the second thing is you
know start with stories sure a lot of
these stories that they use are sort
fantasy fairy tale folktale imagination
as an adult I don't find these stories
very compelling or very interesting I
prefer for example the stories that we
have a link which are daily John works
in a restaurant he's a cook he drives to
work he drives home simple stories that
are relatively meaningless but embody
the most common verbs in the language
they do have some meaning and the
stories repeat the vocabulary over and
over again so to the extent that I'm
motivated to learn the language these
stories in fact are in a way compelling
one other thing is you know I mentioned
in a tweet that I think noticing is a
big issue in language learning because
when we begin learning we just it's just
noise we don't notice anything we don't
notice where one word ends the next word
begins we don't notice the functions of
the words nothing and in time as we
start to save words and start to
understand which words are verbs in
which words are nouns and what they mean
then we start to notice other things we
start to notice connections between
words we start to notice the
pronunciation and so my question is as
an independent learner you know how can
i how can i improve my ability to notice
because when i notice more i learn more
now the minute i said that in a tweet i
get involved in the sort of disputes
that go on in the sort of language
acquisition field where someone has done
noticing hypothesis and there's an
output hypothesis and everyone disagrees
with each other and it's as if the
person who did this noticing hypothesis
and tied this to some kind of deliberate
study of grammar that that has forever
defined the meaning of notice okay my
meaning of notice is different i was
doing the dishes earlier here cleaning
up after breakfast and i'm listening to
our many stories in arabic for the i'm
try don't know 30 or 40 of time and
every time i listen i noticed something
that i hadn't noticed before i'm aware
of myself noticing i'm not deliberately
noticing but i'm
where that I notice an ending or in the
case of Arabic verbs the beginning of
the verb I noticed a certain word that I
hadn't noticed before our certain phrase
I shouldn't say that I hadn't noticed
before I might have noticed and then
forgotten and noticed again and the same
when I review the lessons on my iPad
I've gone through the lesson I've saved
all of you know I've changed all the
blue words that I needed to yell all the
unknown words have been saved so I
review it now before I start reviewing
the lesson the story I go through that
might be 20 yellow links that are in
that lesson I review them in my
flashcards and then I listen to the
story while reading it and I find that
having gone through the flashcards
before the story and this is a lesson
that I've already gone through before
and then when I listen through it again
I notice things in the story better so
at the very least I believe that massive
input helps you notice repetitive
listening and reading helps you notice
some review of flashcards different
activities followed by a review of the
lesson helps you notice having read the
story and then when you go away and
listen to it it helps you notice so
these are some of the things that help
you notice so I'd be interested in in
people's response to this to what extent
are you conscious of noticing things at
certain times maybe forgetting them
again and noticing them again and is
noticing a part of your language
learning process and what things do you
think help you notice all right so there
you have it a brief summary of my
discussion in Portland I can get into
more detail if you want and I wanted to
sort of bring up this discussion of
comprehensible input input based
learning which I agree with and what can
be on the classroom what does the
learner do on his or her own and what is
the role of repetitive operations or or
what are the things that contribute to
improving our ability to notice okay
you for listening I look forward to your
comments bye for now
[Music]